I've now supplied you with two
definitions of the state variable
entropy and it's s for entropy the
thermodynamic definition said that the
change in entropy is equal to the heat
added to a system divided by the
temperature at which the heat is added
so if I obviously if the temperature is
changing while we add the heat which is
normally the case we're going to do a
little bit of calculus and then you can
view this as a mathematical or the
statistical or the common rhetorical
definition of of entropy and this
essentially says that entropy is equal
to some constant times the natural log
of the number of states the system can
take on and this is this case when all
the states are equally probable which is
a pretty good assumption if you have you
know stability and a gazillion molecules
I can have a gazillion gazillion states
you can assume they're all roughly
equally likely there's a slightly more
involved definition if they had
different probabilities but we won't
worry about that now so given that we've
seen these two definitions it's a good
time to introduce you to the second law
of thermodynamics second law and that's
this it's a pretty simple law but it
explains a whole range of phenomena it
tells us that the change in entropy for
the universe the change in entropy for
the universe is when any process is
undergone is always greater than or
equal to zero so that tells us that
whatever when anything ever happens in
the universe the net effect is that the
there's more entropy in the universe
itself and this seems very deep and and
it actually is so let's see if we can
apply it to see why it explains or why
it makes sense relative to some examples
so let's say I have two reservoirs that
are in contact with each other so I have
I have t1 and this is kind of let's call
this our hot reservoir and then I have
t2 I have t2 a cold call this our cold
reservoir well we know from experience
what happens if I put a hot cup of water
and it has it's sharing a wall with a
cold glass of water or cold cube of
water what happens well their
temperature is equalized if these are
the same substance will end up roughly
in between if they're the same
Fay's so essentially we have a transfer
of heat from the hotter substance to the
colder substance so we have some heat Q
that goes from the hotter substance to
the colder substance you don't see an
everyday reality heat going from a cold
or substance to a hotter Stubbins if I
put an ice cube in so let's say some hot
tea you don't see the ice cube getting
colder and the hot tea getting hotter
you see them both getting to some equal
temperature which essentially the tea is
giving heat to the ice cube now in this
situation they're reservoirs so I'm
assuming that their temperatures stay
constant which is a little bit which
would only be the case if they were both
infinite which we know doesn't exist in
the real world in the real world
tyonne's temperatures it gave heat would
go down and teas to temperature would go
up but let's just see whether the second
law of thermodynamics says that this
should happen so what's happening here
if we call what's what's the net change
in entropy 41 so the second law of
thermodynamics says that the change in
entropy for the universe is greater than
zero but in this case that's equal to
the change in entropy 41 plus the change
in entropy for oh I shouldn't I'm going
to call it well let me call it instead
of T 1 let me call it let me call it
just one for system one that's this hot
system up here plus the change in
entropy for system two so it's the
change in entropy for system one it
loses it it loses Q one at a high
temperature so it loses so this equals
this equals minus the heat given to the
system is Q over some hot temperature T
one and then we have the heat being
added to the system T 2 so plus Q over T
2 this is the change in entropy for the
system - right this guy loses the heat
and is at temperature 1 which is a
higher temperature this guy gains the
heat and he it's at a temperature -
which is a colder temperature now is
this going to be greater than zero let's
think about it a little bit if I divide
let me rewrite this so let me I could
rearrange them so that we can write this
as Q over t2
- this one I'm just rearranging it - Q
over t1 now which number is bigger t2 or
t1
well t1 is bigger right this is bigger
bigger now if I have a bigger number
than a bigger than this when I use the
word bigger you have to compare it to
something now 2 1 is bigger than this we
have the same number in the numerator in
both cases right so if I take let's say
1 over some let's say 1/2 minus 1/3
we're going to be bigger than 0 this is
a larger number than this number because
this has a bigger denominator you're
dividing by a larger number that's a
good way to think about it you're
dividing this cube by some number here
to get something and then you're
subtracting that this Q divided by a
larger number so this fraction is going
to be a smaller absolute number so this
is going to be greater than 0 so that
tells the second law of thermodynamics
it verifies this observation we see in
the real world that the temperature will
or that heat will flow from the hot body
to the cold body now you might say hey
Sal I have a I have a case that will
show you that you are wrong you could
say look if I put an air-conditioner in
a room if I put an air-conditioner in a
room let's say this is the room and this
is outside you'll say look what look
what the air-conditioner does the room
is already cold and outside is already
hot but what the air conditioner does is
it makes the cold even colder it makes
the hot even hotter
it takes some queue and it goes in that
direction right it takes heat from the
cold room and puts it out into the hot
air and you're saying this defies the
second law of thermodynamics
you have just disproved it you deserve a
Nobel Prize and I would say to you
you're forgetting one one one small fact
one small fact this air-conditioner
inside here it has some type of a
compressor some type of an engine that's
actively doing this it's putting in work
to make this happen and this engine
right here I'll do it like in magenta
it's also expelling some more heat
so let's call that Q of the the Q of the
engine Q of the engine so if you wanted
to figure out the total entropy created
total entropy for the universe it would
be the entropy of the cold room it'd be
the entropy of the cold room entropy of
the cold room plus the change in entropy
for outside I'll call it outside maybe
I'll call this for the room right so you
might say okay this change in entropy
for the room it's giving away heat let's
say the room is roughly at a constant
temperature for that one millisecond
we're looking at it it's giving away
some Q at some temperature t1 and then
and it's that's a minus and then this
the outside is gaining some heat at some
temperature t2 and so you let me to say
hey this number right here this number
right here is a smaller number than this
one right because this the denominator
is higher so if you just look at this
this would be negative entropy and you'd
say hey this defies the second law of
thermodynamics no but what you have to
throw in here is another notion you have
to throw in here the notion that the
outside is also getting this heat from
the engine so it's also getting this
heat from the engine over the outside
temperature and this term I can
guarantee you I'm not giving you numbers
right now will make this whole
expression positive this this this term
will turn the total net entropy to the
universe to be positive now let's think
a little bit about what entropy is and
what entropy isn't in terms of words so
when you take a a intro chemistry class
the teacher often says entropy entropy
equals disorder which is not incorrect
it it is disorder but you have to be
very careful what we mean by disorder
because the very next example that's
often given is that you know they'll say
look a clean room let's say your bedroom
is clean and then it becomes dirty and
they'll say look the universe became
more disordered the dirty room is is is
is
it has more disorder than the cleanroom
and this is not a case of entropy
increase so this is not a good example
not a good example why is that because
clean and dirty are just states of the
room
remember entropy entropy is a macrostate
variable it's a macrostate variable it's
something you use to describe a system
where you're not in the mood to sit
there and tell me what exactly every
particle is doing and this is a macro
variable that actually tells me how much
how much time would it take for me to
tell you what every what every particle
is doing it actually tells you how many
states there are how much information I
would have to give you to tell you the
exact state now when you have a clean
room in a dirty room these are two
different states of the same room if the
room is if the room has the same
temperature it has the same number of
molecules in it and everything then they
have the same entropy so clean to dirty
it's not more entropy now if you had a
nap for example I can have a dirty cold
room dirty cold room and let's say I
were to go into that room and and you
know I work really hard to clean it up
and by doing so I had a lot of heat to
the system and my sweat molecules drop
all over the place and so there's just
more stuff in that room it's all warmed
up to me so - a hot clean room clean
room with with with sweat in it with
sweat so it's got more stuff in here it
can be configured in more ways and
because it's hot every molecule in the
room can take on more states right
because the average kinetic energy is up
so they can kind of explore the the
spaces of how many kinetic energies they
can have there's no there's more
potential energies that each molecule
can take on this is actually an increase
in entropy from a dirty cold room to a
hot clean room and this actually goes
well with what we're now into a room and
I start cleaning it I am putting heat
into the room and the universe is
becoming more I guess we could say it's
the entropy is increasing so where where
does the term disorder apply where does
the term to sort apply well let's take a
situation where I take
a ball I take the ball and it falls to
the ground and then it hits the ground
and there should have been a question
that you've been asking all the time
since the first law of thermodynamics
once the ball hits the ground so the
ball hits the ground right when it got
thrown up it had some potential artery
to the top then that gall gets turned
into kinetic energy hits the ground then
it stops and so your obvious question
said what happened to all of that energy
right a lot the conservation of energy
where did all of it go ahead all that
kinetic energy right before the ground
that it stopped right it seems like it
disappeared but it didn't disappear so
when the ball was falling it had a bunch
of Mahlon these everything had a little
bit of heat but let's say you know the
ground was reasonably ordered it was
reasonably ordered they were probably
vibrating the ground molecules were
vibrating with some with some kinetic
energy and potential energies and then
our ball molecules were also vibrating a
little bit but most of their motion was
downwards right most of the ball
molecules motion was downwards now when
it hits the ground what happens let me
see the interface of the ball so the
ball the ball molecules at the front of
the ball are going to look like that
there's a bunch of them it's a solid
it'll maybe be some type of lattice and
then it hits the ground and when it hits
the ground so the ground is another
solid like that all right we're looking
at the Mac of the microstate what's
going to happen these guys are going to
rub up against these guys and they're
going to transfer their what was
downward kinetic energy and a very
ordered downward kinetic energy they're
going to transfer it to these two these
ground particles and they're going to
bump into the ground particles and so
when this guy bumps into that guy he
might start moving in that direction
this guy will start oscillating in that
direction and go back and forth like
that that guy might bounce off of this
guy and go in that direction and bump
into that guy and go into that direction
and then because that guy bumped here
this guy bumps here and because this guy
bumps here this guy bumps over there and
so what you have is what you what was
relatively ordered motion especially
from the balls point of view
when it starts rubbing up against these
molecules of the ground it starts making
the kinetic energy or their movement go
in all sorts of random directions right
this guy is going to make this guy go
like that and that guy go like that and
so when the movement is no longer
ordered forget it if I have a lot of
molecules let me do it in a different
color if I have a lot of molecules and
they're all moving in the exact same
direction then my microstate looks like
my macro state the whole thing moves in
that direction now if I have a bunch of
molecules and they're all moving in
random directions my ball as a whole
will be stationary I could have the
exact same amount of kinetic energy at
the molecular level but they're all
going to be bouncing into each other and
in this case we described the kinetic
energy as internal energy or we
described it as temperature or you know
where temperature is the average kinetic
energy so in this case when we talk
about the world is becoming more
disordered you think about the order of
the maybe the velocities or the energies
of the molecules before they were
reasonably ordered the molecules they
might have been vibrating a little bit
but they were mainly going down in the
ball but when they bump into the ground
all of a sudden they start vibrating in
random directions a little bit more and
they make the ground vibrate in more
random directions so it makes all at the
microstate everything became just that
much more disordered now there's an
interesting question here there is some
probability you know you might think
look you know this ball came down and
hit the ground why doesn't the ball just
you know isn't there some probability
that if I have a ground if like that
these molecules just rearrange
themselves and just the right way to
just pop these two just hit these these
ball molecules in just the right way
there's some probability just from the
random movement that on its some second
all of the ground molecules just hit the
ball molecules just right to send the
ball back up and the answer is yes
there's actually some infinitesimally
small chance that that happens that you
could have a ball that's sitting on the
ground and this is interesting you can
have a ball that's sitting on the ground
and while you're looking you'll probably
have to wait a few gazillion years for
it to happen if it happens at all it
could just randomly pop up and that's
some red so there's some random very
small chance
that these molecules just randomly
vibrate in just the right way to be
ordered for a second and then the ball
will pop up but this does not the
probability of this happening relative
to everything else is essentially zero
so when people talk about order and
disorder the disorder is increasing
because now these molecules are going in
more random directions and they can take
on more potential states and we saw that
here and you know it on some level
entropy seemed something kind of magical
but on some level it seemed something it
seems relatively common sense in that
video it to video I think it was the
last video I had the case where I had a
bunch of molecules and then I had this
extra space here and then I removed the
wall and we saw that these molecules the
these molecules will I mean you know we
know there's there's always some
molecules are bouncing off this wall
before because we probably had some
pressure associated with it and then as
soon as we remove that wall the molecule
that would have bounced there just keeps
going just keeps going there's nothing
to stop it from there in that direction
there's a lot of stuff it could bump
into other molecules and it could bump
into these walls but in this direction
the odds of it bumping into everything
is especially for these leading
molecules is essentially zero so it's
going to expand to fill the container so
that's kind of common sense but the neat
thing is that the second law of
thermodynamics as we saw in that video
also says that this will happen that the
molecules will all expand to fill the
container and that the odds of this
happening are very low that they all
come back they all come back and go into
an ordered State now there is some
chance just from the random movements
once they feel that they all just happen
to come back here but it's a very very
small probability and even more and I
want to make this very clear s is a
macro state macro state we never talk
about the entropy for an individual
molecule if we know what an individual
molecule is doing we shouldn't be
worried about entropy we should be
worrying about the system as a whole the
system as a whole so even if we're
looking at this system even if we're
looking at the system if we're not
looking directly at the molecules we
won't even know that this hat
we won't even know that this actually
happened all we can do is look at the
statistical properties of the molecules
how many molecules they are what their
temperature is all their macro dynamics
their pressure
and say you know what a box that has
these molecules has more state than a
smaller box in the box when we had the
wall there
even if by chance all of the molecules
happen to be collecting over there we
wouldn't know that that happened because
we're not looking at the microstates and
that's a really important thing to
consider when someone says that a dirty
room is has a higher entropy than a than
a clean room they're looking at the
microstate and entropy essentially is a
macro state variable you could just say
that a room has a certain um amount of
entropy so entropy is associated with
the room with the room and it's only
useful when you really don't know
exactly what's going on in the room you
just have a general sense of how much
stuff there's in the room what's the
temperature of the room what's the
pressure in the room just the general
macro properties and then entropy will
essentially tell us how many possible
microstates that macro system can
actually have or how much information
and there's there's a notion of
information entropy how much information
would I have to get you give you to tell
you exactly where every what the exact
microstate is of a system at that point
in time
well anyway hopefully you found this
discussion a little bit useful and
clears up some misconceptions about
entropy and gives you a little bit more
intuition about what it actually is see
in the next video